Now let's look at the kernel itself.
Recall that this will look like a serial program that will run on one thread,
and the CPU is responsible for launching that program on many parallel threads.
This kernel indeed looks exactly like a serial program.
So here's our kernel right here, this global void square.
Here's the interesting things about this short kernel program. First global.
This is underscore, underscore, global, underscore, underscore.
That's a C language construct called a "declaration specifier"--for short, deckle speck.
Don't worry about the name.
Just know that this is the way that cuda knows this code is a kernel as opposed to CPU code.
Next we have void.
Void just means the kernel doesn't return a value.
Instead it writes the output into the pointer specified in its argument list.
This kernel takes two arguments.
These are pointers to the output and the input arrays.
Recall that both these pointers need to be allocated on the GPU, or else your program will crash spectacularly.
Now note that I name them with d out and d in.
That's certainly not foolproof, but if I called it d_
and I'm consistent about the way I allocate my variables,
I know that d_ variables are allocated on the GPU.
Let's walk through the body of the kernel.
So the first line of the body here.
Remember how I said that each thread know its own index?
Here's how we get that index.
CUDA has a built in variable called thread index, threadIDX,
and that's going to tell each thread its index within a block.
ThreadIDX is actually a c struct with 3 members. .x, .y, and .z. The c struct is called a dim3.
We're just using .x in this code, but we'll explain the others a little bit later.
Now, we'll launch 64 threads.
For the first instance of those threads, threadIDX.x will return zero,
for the second instance 1, and so on, up to 63 for the last element.
Everything else in this kernel just looks like straightforward C.
It looks just like a serial program.
What are we actually doing in this kernel?
Well, for each thread we're going to first read the array element corresponding
to this thread index from global memory.
We're going to store it in this float variable f.
We're then going to square f, and we're going to write that value back to global memory
in the output array element that corresponds to our thread index.